un hommage avant de refermer cette
édition un hommage que rend le chanteur
philippe léotard au poète léo ferré un
hommage en forme de tournée à travers
toute la france
thiriez et didier rancoeurs ont suivi en
breton monsieur léotard a le visage
comme une page d'écriture comme féret
monsieur léotard et mme boulet sa vie
sans tricher comme ferrer monsieur
léotard c'est que le mal qui est fait
par les hommes ne peut jamais être des
faits comme ferrer monsieur léotard n'a
pas connu léo ferré plus de 40 minutes
mais pour les eaux la tendresse le vieux
léo la révolte a toujours beaucoup
compté je chantais tout bon achat j'aime
mieux et chantent et jaguar mais au
dessus
l'oral de rattrapage alors pg japon là
elle alors si des il n'y a rien de juste
qui fait la loi
une voix éraillée d'avoir trop aimé la
vie et surtout une plainte une tendresse
une modestie ses rites ses grimaces le
poids de 4 phantom son père devert
coluche gainsbourg tous amis tous partis
quelques ruptures quelques brûlures et
l'ancien porte de philosophie c'est une
philosophie plus dur est fait de la
bouche du jeune fille soit seulement
c'est quand même si le spectacle
j'étais professeur j'ai vu des jeunes
gens et jeunes filles tous beaux à 15
ans pas beaucoup de récupérable à tron
qu'est ce qu'on veut mais qu'est ce
qu'on leur a fait j'ai vécu au jour des
merveilles vous et moi souvenez vous en
j'ai fauché le mur des scellés ou en
tournée sans tapis rouge
juste un petit nez parce que la vie
n'est qu'un théâtre qu'il le sait comme
féret